[Music]
hey guys today we are checking out the
new techno camen 19 phone and you may be
wondering what exactly is that i
partnered with techno to show you guys
this device techno has been producing
devices in various global regions
including africa latin america the
middle east southeast and southern asia
so here it is meet the techno canon 19.
this is the eco black color with 120
hertz 6.7 inch full hd amoled display
and up to 500 nits of brightness it has
a 500 milliamp battery usb c connection
fingerprint sensor on the side and you
can get up to eight gigs of ram you'll
also notice this has an incredibly slim
design which is .98 millimeters and very
very tiny bezels around the edge so the
display takes up almost the entire front
of the device it's also very light and
it features these two circular camera
lenses on the back i really like the
unique look of these this actually has
three lenses on it this top is a 64
megapixel super night camera and this is
the two megapixel bokeh lens and this is
the 50 millimeter portrait focus lens
this also features a flash right here
and under here which is kind of hard to
see is where the laser focus and optical
image stabilization is housed this of
course does also have a front-facing
camera and that is 32 megapixels now one
of the big highlights for this device is
the 64 megapixel super night portrait
which they are calling the most human i
like image sensor it has a camon 19 pro
rgbw camera sensor with a customized
glass lens that was co-developed with
samsung now when it comes to mobile
devices i am always so excited to test
out the camera and this has a super fast
focus response time of 0.1 seconds this
also helps with image stabilization for
nighttime shooting and capturing motion
i also really love this feature it has a
touch to click to change the sky now i'm
not going to lie i do often add in
better looking skies and clouds in a lot
of my photos that i post so this is
making it so easy to do right on your
mobile device so in the ai settings
there's a little section called sky shop
so when you click that it gives you all
of these sky options and it's cool
because i can choose from them and i can
actually see them changing on the screen
as i move and switch the filters but
first i'm going to take a photo without
the sky shop so you can see where we
started and where we've ended up kind of
like you know we started from the bottom
now we're
here there's our regular photo heading
into sky shop oh man okay okay okay so
the first one is sunny
okay
now here's rainbow oh my god there's a
rainbow
that looks so good azure sky is our next
one
oh my gosh that's awesome also love it
this one is
rosie
sunset
this one's twilight
so this one's starry this is wild it
basically made this whole shot looked
like it was
knight
this one's galaxy here's meteor
these are so cool here's orbit
dude i'm freaking out this is actually
way cooler than i thought it was gonna
be
this one's aurora
and now our last one we have moon
wow this is awesome i'm super impressed
this also has some fun ai features and
this will automatically detect what
you're taking photos of this will allow
for the camera to kind of auto adjust to
make sure you're getting the perfect
shot of whatever it is that you're
taking a photo of every single time this
also has a camera film mode feature and
it gives you these customized filters
for different scenes like sports parties
or capturing motion this has a really
cool camera mode called pro mode and
this will let you adjust all kinds of
settings manually just like you would do
on a manual camera this gives you all of
those same options to try to perfect
that perfect shot video is of course
something that i absolutely love testing
out i'm also a huge fan of hdr so this
does have video hdr with hdr it allows
you to have more control over those
really bright areas in your video and
also the dark areas i film a lot of
videos out about on the go traveling
filming my dog a lot of times and
this has an extra stabilization mode
that you can turn on and i absolutely
love this because it will give you extra
stability when you're filming or moving
around just to make your shots extra
steady another really fun feature is
video portrait now you'll notice the
background of this video is blurred so
in this mode it kind of gives you that
effect of using various high-end lenses
this bokeh will also work for up to
three people in the frame and it can be
adjusted to your liking so we're now
outside and it's time to test out taking
some photos and some videos and i'm
gonna start by just kind of going
through all of the features so we're
gonna start with photos and the cool
thing is with the ai cam is it's able to
determine what you're taking a photo of
are you taking a picture of the street
are you taking a picture of some plants
flowers first up some photos i now have
this clicked onto the 64 megapixel ai
camera and i've got some flowers behind
me so let's take a shot and see how they
look so the first shot i have
oh it says flower
it knew
so this is shot with the 64 megapixel
and now i'm going to also click off of
the 64 megapixel to see what that looks
like and it still is showing us that
it's a plant and a flower oh there's
some more flowers over here oh
64 megapixel is on
64 megapixel is off
so you click the ai button this has a
little color enhancement so let's do a
shot of this flower with the ai color
enhancement on and i'll show you the
comparison between the two
so there you have it here's the color
enhanced version up against the
non-color enhanced version obviously it
just looks like the saturation has been
turned up slightly both photos i think
look great this feels like a real
portrait setting if i do say so myself
uh nathan would you take some portrait
photos here using the portrait setting
yes
i'm gonna test out one of the little
film templates they basically give you a
few seconds to record you shoot it edits
it together adds music it's magic i love
ai editing shot are a few seconds of the
video in each one and it just made me an
auto-generated movie this is so cool
check it out
[Music]
so we're back here in the park where you
last saw me filming you may notice it's
dark it's nighttime there is
some light around in this park so
obviously there is going to be some
light leaks i'm so excited to test this
out now that it's dark out it's really
cool because it's already adjusting in
the ai settings it's already changing to
the night mode and i even brought my
little tripod so did i bring my tripod
oh my god i did yes here it is phone
tripod so i can do some super steady
shots even though a lot of mobile phones
do a pretty good job at stabilization at
night time i don't care how incredible
your phone is or your camera having a
tripod to take night photos it just
makes everything so much better
obviously a lot of people don't carry
around tripods with them everywhere they
go so it is great to kind of see what it
does look like handheld mode if you're a
photographer and you're looking to get
the shot just get yourself a tiny tripod
it's
life-changing
[Music]
wow it almost looks like it's daylight
out
so as you guys can see or not see it is
pretty dark out right now so i'm going
to try to take a few photos and even
test out the night video it is kind of
cool because as soon as i start taking a
photo or video you can see that the ai
automatically picks up that it's dark
out and to switch to the night mode okay
let's get ourselves a little night video
shot here and you can see that it does
automatically switch to night video here
it is night mode video i love testing
out cameras on mobile devices so this is
always so much fun to go out and do
tests like this and as you can see it's
night time morning night video that's my
story and i'm sticking to it
oh there's also like some children's
artwork here that's really nice
very nice work
palm trees
looking good
i'm gonna turn up the iso on here
because you guys can't not see me at all
that is the great part about having a
massive camera like this with a big
sensor you can obviously turn it up and
adjust and it is kind of difficult
though in mobile devices because you
don't have that massive sensor to deal
with so it is always impressive to see
what you can actually get from mobile
phones nowadays this just gave me a
prompt and it wanted to switch into
super night mode let's see what that
looks like
that looks good
let's take a photo without super night
on
and see what that looks like here is
regular and here is super night
okay the one thing you will definitely
notice though in the super night photo
is the detail in the trees everything
looks way more crisp it's also pulling
out some of the stars in the sky i'm
gonna walk around take some more photos
and i'll show you guys what i managed to
capture
[Music]
well guys thank you so much for watching
i had so much fun getting a chance to
check out this device and it was really
fun because normally this isn't
something that i would get a chance to
review a huge thank you to techno for
partnering with me again on this video
and getting me one of these devices to
check out if you guys want more
information i will put a link in the
description and for now i am i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to bed because it's late
and i go to bed really early so it's
like as soon as the the sun starts going
down
that means it's time for sleep so i'll
see you guys later bye
[Music]